premier ministre en 2022
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a imaginé de
michel houellebecq dans son dernier
roman et en attendant sa voix compte et
il pourrait bien faire la différence à
la présidentielle encore cette année
voici françois bayrou
alors pour toi
bonsoir françois bayrou avant de le
blesser dans les griffes de nos deux
eric g pour vous un petit qcm ça va bien
enfin si la primaire de la gauche
c'est une petite mise en bouche est-ce
que vous voterez pour françois hollande
emmanuel macron arnaud montebourg benoît
hamon
il est jeune et les autres messieurs un
commentaire pourquoi pourquoi donc vous
ne voterez pas la primaire de gauche
sûrement pas vous faut que vous
comprenez une chose qui aujourd'hui
c'est un peu en fils d esprit il ya deux
sortes de responsables politiques
ceux qui acceptent que le pays soit
coupée en deux entre ces deux fictions
qui s'appelle l'une gauche et l'autre
droite et ceux qui ne l'acceptent pas
j'appartiens à la catégorie de ceux qui
ne l'acceptent pas et donc la
primarisation de la vie politique le le
fait qu'on veuille organiser des
primaires sous toutes ses formes pour
découper la france en deux camps dans
lesquels on serait
obligé mis aux ordres de se trouver est
pour moi quelque chose qui ne correspond
pas à ce que je crois enfin si j'ai
bonne mémoire vous avez appelé à voter
pour hollande en 2012 quand même et
alors vous avez choisi un camp comme non
pas du tout j'ai choisi et c'est
peut-être il faut que vous fassiez ce
travail pour y réfléchir s'agit pas de
choisir un camp l'élection
présidentielle c'est l'élection d'un
président de la république d'accord et
on est au deuxième tour dans une vous
savez que j'étais candidat au premier
tour on est au deuxième tour dans une
situation ou bien on accepte ou bien on
refuse que le sortant soit reconduit et
je pensais avec des arguments qui
apparaissent tous les jours plus
éclatant que la reconduction de nicolas
sarkozy aurait été pour le pays quelque
chose qui vraiment n'allait pas dans le
bon sens et je choisis les mots les plus
les plus doux pour vous dire ce genre de
choses je et donc oui j'ai voté pour
françois hollande mais pour autant j'ai
refusé d'adhérer à un temps je me suis
fait battre aux élections législatives
vous reprenez vous auriez calais mais
qu'ils soient gentils avec vous non pas
du tout qu'il fallait justement c'est la
deuxième question françois hollande en
rien j'ai accouché à chaque instant de
ma vie
refusez précisément ce que vous appelez
les gentillesses ses statuts bah oui et
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
les gagner pour parce que vous êtes
revenu dans le camp de la balle du tout
j'ai gagné pô parce que je me suis
imposé avec une liste qui était
totalement centrale avec des gens de
gauche et de droite et que l'opposition
comme je crois que ça doit être
nécessaire et que le
l'ump de l'époque étant très très bas
dans les sondages a choisi de se rallier
à moi ça rien du c'est pas moi je suis
réaliste et vous devriez savoir que
précisément ceci est ma philosophie
je ne me rallie pas et je peux tout à
fait accepté que les autres au contraire
viennent travailler avec moi alors
deuxième question françois hollande
réélu ça serait une bonne nouvelle une
catastrophe ni pire ni mieux qu'un autre
vous ne croyez pas aux miracles à part à
lourdes
ah non j'ai preuve je crois pas du tout
à la réélection de françois hollande
et je ne pense pas que ce serait une
bonne nouvelle donc ça serait une bonne
nouvelle puisqu'il ne sera pas réélu
vous savez que je vais écrire vous savez
que je le lui ai dit depuis très
longtemps et face à sarkozy
si on si on rejouait lamego vous veut
vous avez beaucoup de talent vous avez
un sourire tout à fait convaincant mais
vous ne me tirerais pas dans la valse
des six va y aller tranquillement vos
déclarations vous sentez vous le plus
proche
sarkozy ces barbes à papa ça c'est
marine le pen
béraud c'est le clapotis de la décadence
savez qu'il ya dix ans ce n'est pas moi
qui me sarkozy ces gens c'est sarkozy
qui se jean maryse et si j'y vais c'est
pour gagner moi de m de quoi vous sorte
de code
j'y vais j'y vais c'est pour gagner
alors comme ça hollande c'était facile
j'y vais c'est pour gagner là vraiment
si j'avais été là c'est pour gagner mais
vous êtes présenté trois fois oui et
vous n'avez pas gagné
et alors ah bah moi je trouve que les
116 françois mitterrand s'est présentée
il a gagné la troisième il a gagné la
troisième cherchent à occire accès
présenté trois fois il a gagné la
troisième vous avez raté le coche non je
je je pense pas qu'on puisse rire de
tout dans ce genre de choses et même je
trouve que c'est pas le lieu je pense
que quand un homme politique croit à
quelque chose
il doit être capable de se faire battre
pour ce qu'il croit sachez qu'il doit
refuser en toutes circonstances de se
rallier de s'humilier de passer à des
gens dont ils considèrent qu'ils ont pas
les mêmes options que les sciences mais
on peut avoir des nuances mais je me
suis acceptée et donc j'ai justement
parler de ça excusez moi rien n'est joué
aux honorables à mes yeux que d'aller au
combat et j'ai refusé de se rendre de
défendre ce qu'on croit essentiel est qu
importe le risque d'affecter des noms
ben si vous avez dit vous avez raté le
coche janvier mois et donc les amoureux
d'art
voilà un peu un peu de sarcasme n'est
pas méchant vous savez la taquinerie la
gentillesse des méchants disait victor
hugo et mais le prof vous allergiques
asthme le parlera du sarcasme qui n'est
pas de l'humour
le king cette fois ce n'est pas la
taquinerie non plus si ce n'est la cité
une taquinerie bon soyons précis
non non et non
vous avez suffisamment mis la phrase
bayrou c'est le clapotis de la décadence
parce que c'était manuel macron qui a
dit ça qu'est ce que vous pensez lui
justement là ils étaient vexés de ce que
j'avais dit je comprends moi je l'aurais
été à sa place aussi donc bah j'avais
dit que il avait été le principal
inspirateur et le principal organisateur
de la politique économique avait suivi
françois hollande qu'il a fait voter une
loi qui s'appelle croissance et on est
aujourd'hui en croissance négative on
est à moins de zéro et une loi pour
l'emploi et on est avec au mois d'août
soixante quinze mille chômeurs de plus
bien c'était pas évidemment extrêmement
gentil je suis en désaccord avec la
politique qu'il a suivie et je suis en
désaccord avec son approche de la
politique voilà pourtant ils vous
ressemblez au départ on comparait
souvent vous on disait ni gauche ni
droite a louvoyé 1 je suis pas sûr qu'il
ait jamais dit ni gauche ni droite mais
moi je suis sûr de ne l'avoir jamais dit
ça n'a jamais été mon vous suffit donc
gauche et droite
non moi si les meilleurs de la gorge et
les maires de la droite autour d'une
seule carte politique ceci là c'était
autre chose c'est moi je crois non
seulement je crois mais j'espère prouver
à chaque instant qu'il y a une politique
différente qui s'appelle centre qui a
des des traits des caractéristiques
absolument différente de la droite dé
droite parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus une seule droite il ya
multiplication de droite et des gaufres
et explosion de la glace
cependant il y a une politique du centre
en tout cas que j'ai pour laquelle je me
suis battu et que je me suis attaché à
définir au travers du temps et c'est
cette politique là que je suis je suis
pas dans le relais le ni ni la double
négation qu'il ya des choses tout à fait
tout à fait à côté de la plaque à mes
yeux
d'accord je laisse rien parce que c'est
le coeur de mon interrogation très
aimable je vous remercie infiniment je
suis trop bon
problème avec alain juppé c'est ma
dernière question c'est qu'il n'est plus
tout jeune c'est qu'il sera battu par
sarkozy aux primaires c'est qu'il leur
ait fait rêver personne à part vous
françois verrons où c'est qu'il a quand
même quelques casseroles mais comme il
l'a dit lui même
en début de semaine et en affaires
judiciaires il vaut mieux avoir un passé
qu'un avenir
voilà bah moi je vois pas de problème
avec alain juppé alors j'ai pas tout à
fait les mêmes idées que lui sur tous
les sujets on a des nuances on a des
différences mais c'est quelqu'un que
j'estime c'est bizarre le ca arrive pas
souvent politique que quelqu'un qui a un
socle de voix vient de dire écoutez moi
je suis prêt à travailler avec celui là
avec un autre et je suis prêt à
travailler avec alain juppé parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui je trouve est je
vais employer un mot que n'emploie pas
souvent en politique est honorable
comprenez que quelqu'un quand en tout
cas je parle avec lui ou que je
travaille avec lui ça fait des années
que à huy que nous nous connaissons ça
fait 30 ans j'ai ouï c'est quelqu'un que
dont j'ai toujours pensé qu'il ne
mettait pas son intérêt en premier et
que donc c'était suffisamment rare et
que d'autre part à mon truc est tombé là
et que d'autre part le le choix qui est
le sien et qui est le mien aussi que
pour réformer un pays il faut leur
assemblée ce choix là est le bon c'est à
dire qu'il refuse de passer son temps à
mettre le feu aux affrontements entre
français qui ne demande qu à flamber
alors juste ma part je peine après la
savane et sèche
on appréhende et refuse de madrid a dû
mettre je trouve ça plutôt bien
on a préparé un petit sujet pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est la question qui fâche
de dimitri queffélec
j'ai pour alain juppé beaucoup d'estimé
c'est quelqu'un qui peut faire du bien
au pays
bayrou juppé ou l'histoire d'une
alliance après trois candidatures à la
présidentielle françois bayrou vous vous
rangez désormais derrière le meilleur
d'entre nous et cette première question
ce soutien n'est t'il pas d'abord celui
d'un anti sarkozyste d'autant qu'on
renvoie les fons et aux gaulois et les
gabonais au gabon on ne parle pas des
vrais sujets qui nous avait comme
principal allié
celui qui a aidé françois hollande
arrivé au pouvoir qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez changer de politique
non ce que vous conseillez top ou encore
françois bayrou a connu pour les
sarkozystes le crime du team qui est
d'avoir voté pour françois hollande en
le vote pour françois hollande c'est le
choix que je fais très chaud bayrou qui
n'ont pas ou il est lui même
c'est tellement compliqué puisque la
sarkozie après un bon score de premier
tour s'est livré à une course poursuite
à l'extrême droite dans laquelle nous ne
retrouvons pas nos valeurs
une rivalité ancienne au cours d'un
débat télévisé en 1999 l'ambiance
c'était déjà quelque peu tendue
nicolas sarkozy à nous les baisses
d'impôts tu parles
lorsqu'on a été au pouvoir on les a
augmenté de 120 milliards je bayrou il
était temps monsieur hollande attend de
la carnoy valero nous n'avons pas à nous
dire quand tu parles c'est la vérité
quand je parle cette mention et permet
moi de te dire que s'agissant du
gouvernement a affirmé que tu puisses tu
en étais engagé quoi mais au delà du
rejet commun de nicolas sarkozy qu'elles
sont françois bayrou
les motivations qui pour la prochaine
présidentielle vous pousse à rester sur
la touche
je suis heureux qu'alain juppé ait
montré qu'il était un homme de volonté
qu'il était un homme de parole et qu'il
était se faisant un homme d'honneur au
fond il ya une sorte de pacte qui a été
scellé entre alain juppé françois bayrou
et françois bayrou veut pas l'adouber
gagne encore une année à vous-même
france aubert parce que je pense que le
moment a besoin de rassemblement et que
la candidature d'alain juppé offre une
chance à ce rassemblement la veille cela
se produit pas ma fille ça se produit
m'a je prendrai des responsables
alors françois bayrou questions qui
fâchent nous confirmez vous ce soir
qu'en cas d'échec d'alain juppé à la
primaire vous vous lancerez vous même à
la conquête de la présidentielle
je pose je connais pas un seul le roman
de renart kipling qui s'appelle l'homme
qui voulut être roi c'était vous serez
point que j'aime beaucoup qui plus est
ben voilà à 3,3 soit candidat à la
présidentielle maintenant vous êtes
l'homme qui veut faire mille fois
candidat
autrefois trois fois candidat à la
présidentielle mais c'était sur une
distance de 7 en deux voilà des noms
mais ce n'est plus le cas l'homme qui
voulait être heureux maintenant c'est
l'homme qui veut faire les rois hollande
hier juppé demain et dans le même temps
où nous expliquer que vous êtes le
promoteur d'un centre autonome que vous
voulez un carnet et c'est bien votre
droit donc là j'arrive pas à comprendre
comment vous vous résolvez cette
contradiction comment à moins que ce
soit sarkozy qui gagne les primaires
vous ne voulez pas y aller c'est à dire
vous reconnaissez que juppé incarne quoi
l'intégralité des valeurs centristes
je pense que alain juppé est aujourd'hui
le mieux placé
oui de ce qu'ils peuvent faire en sorte
qu'un rassemblement ait lieu que la vie
politique française sorte de ces de
cette ornière dans laquelle elle se
trouve que la vie politique française
quitte les les
les excitations du sectarisme
parce que c'est là dedans convient de
types qui font semblant d'être du même
parti alors qu'ils pensent le contraire
sur à peu près tous les sujets d'accords
et qu' il y a dans l'option d'alain
juppé quelque chose qui nous permet de
faire autrement de nous en sortir de
reconstruire le centre en france et de
faire que les les faux semblants
disparaissent connaît une autre approche
de la politique il est moins partisan
que les autres je dis pas qu'ils ac n'a
jamais été par quoi bon quand même
enfin quand même été secrétaire général
de la vendée de la bouche et à l'homme
c'est pas une âme non mais il était
parti comme il l'a été je me suis
confronté avec ses procès
je pensais bien par moments assez sévère
dans amicalement les sévèrement je crois
qu'il dirait la même chose
bon il est moins partisan on a besoin de
gens moins partisan aujourd'hui à
condition qu'ils pensent quelque chose
et à condition qu'ils soient en phase
avec ce que vous croyez ce que je crois
ce que aujourd'hui peut-être que la
majorité du pays j'entends n'était pas
si mal posée ici il ne passe pas la
primaire eh bien je reviendrai vous voir
tout est bon mais j'aurai quelque chose
à vous dire je ne comprends pas comment
vous voulez reconstruire un centre en
faisant allégeance à quelqu'un je ne
fais aucune allégeance ma nature n'est
pas de faire allégeance je crois qu'on a
pu même assez souvent de voir comment ça
y ressemble pas du tout à dire je n'y
verrai je suis prêt à le soutenir
soutien à les ont séparés mais aussi
parce que vous renoncez à votre propre
et bien pas du tout oui enfin ouais ben
oui parce que sans ça ça n'aurait pas de
sens que je me présente contre quelqu'un
avec qui je partage un très grand nombre
d'idées de valeur mais le premier tour
risquerait d'être détestable pour tout
le monde c'est la discussion tout à
l'heure les dangers comme hier voilà
c'est la belle discussion qu'on a eue
tout aller voilà donc que lorsque
quelqu'un est bien placé aujourd'hui le
mieux placé de tout ce qu'ils peuvent
c'est l'histoire c'est le hasard c'est
la providence c'est vous appelez ça
comme vous voulez dans ce quelqu'un sol
y trouvent dans cette situation là eh
bien je trouve moi qu'il est digne de
dire je vais lui apporter mon soutien
d'accord je l'aiderai accord et vous
dites que vous travaillerez avec lui oui
mais dans quel cadre parce que en fait
vous avez dit aussi que vous pouvez pas
être son premier ministre qu'un premier
ministre va tirer sa légitimité du parti
donc sa légitimité c'est pas le bon mot
mais disons que parce qu'il est désigné
par donc il est légitime examen la
question c'est que du point de vue des
équipes de l' équilibre des forces
il vaut mieux que le premier ministre
soit le choix
l'élection immédiatement passé
appartiennent au parti le plus nombreux
de la majorité
dans mes sacs dans l'équation actuelle
je vous rappelle que que bon c'est le
parti de nicolas sarkozy je suis pas sûr
qu ils m'accueillent ray avec sa triste
on ferait pas ce que je suis extrêmement
aimable mais ça tout le monde le sait
mais moi j'aimerais vous dire que il
n'est pas sûr que les disposer pas à
vous que je vais apprendre que les
dispositions partisanes pour échanger au
cas où nous aurions juppé face à marine
le pen et que une partie importante de
la gauche à loyer vous à eghezée moi je
sais que vous avez compris ce que j'ai
dit si vous prenez mes défauts je veux
dire ça sert plus rien donc je
plaisanterie mise à part je finis ma
phrase si une partie de la gauche
importante ralliait évidemment alain
juppé contre marine le pen c'est ce qui
est arrivé aux régionales pour estrosi
et bertrand est donc dans ce cas là vous
seriez au contraire le point d'équilibré
entre c'est toute cette majorité du pays
eh bien voyez-vous eric zemmour je n'y
avais jamais pensé c'est la première
fois de ma vie que cette perspective
paraît vous m'avez mais suggère vous
m'avez ouvert on avait dit allez je le
prends rien passé je dit du bien de vous
et je dis pas je dis pas vous avez raté
le coche de plus on paie pas mais mon
chez moi donc c'est pareil vous de jouer
m'a jamais parce que je sens bien qu'il
ya le dim natation là vous êtes très
intelligent et ma faute je n'avais
jamais pensé à ça bon alors maintenant
vous allez vous allez à mai mais sérieux
je ne dis pas que ce soit absurde eu ce
que blanc sait pas alors une chose qui
n'est pas absurde selon mais qui va plus
vous agacer quand vous dit tout à
l'heure vous claquez macron j'ai bien
compris sur c'est l'homme de la banque
l'homme de l'argent
moi j'ai moi même écrit que c'était les
habits neufs de la classe dominante donc
on est d'accord sur le diagnostic
en revanche il ya quelque chose que je
ne comprends pas et même que je n'admets
pas c'est qu'on voulu fait le reproche
d'avoir appliqué va être à l'origine de
la politique économique de hollande et
que par exemple vous lui reprochez comme
comme d'autres d'ailleurs à droite
d'avoir augmenté considérablement les
impôts et vous faites semblant de ne pas
voir que ils ont fait ça pour se mettre
dans les clous des 3% de maastricht
vous savez très bien qu'ils ont fait ça
pour justement être les bons élèves de
l'europe contrairement à sarkozy vous
vous souvenez qui est émis en 2007 qui
avait insulté tout le monde et qui leur
avait dit que c'est ce qu'on est et toi
vous sarkozy dans le texte et plus
profondément
plus profondément il vous avez un
problème selon moi qui est majeur depuis
20 ans c'est que vous nous expliquer qu'
il y à la droite il y à la gauche et que
vous en avez assez de la droite et de la
gauche que vous voulez faire la
politique du centre
sauf que depuis 25 ans depuis maastricht
la droite et la gauche font la même
politique qui est celle du centre c'est
à dire celle de bruxelles
donc vous pouvez pas venir nous dire ces
abrutis de droite et ses méchants de
gauche font une politique idiote
alors que cette politique idiote c'est
la vôtre ou plutôt c'est celle de
bruxelles
et c'est celle que vous soutenez depuis
25 ans donc tout est à peu près faut
dans ce cas banon tout est à poprad
wright alors je vais je vais savourer
pas dire que c'est leur argument je
l'avais essayé ben je vais pimenté je
suis là pour ça 1 vous eu
l'erreur fondamentale qui est la vôtre
depuis longtemps c'est de faire croire
que nous en sommes où nous en sommes à
cause de l'europe de la mondialisation
de bruxelles de à cause d'eux
cela qu'est ce qui est marquant dans la
situation de la france éducation en
capilotade catastrophe éducative
fiscalité excessive incapacité à trouver
une place respectable et simplifié pour
l'entreprise prolifération
administrative perpétuelle perpétuelle
ambiance de défiance à l'intérieur du
pays
débat vous avez oublié landel simpliste
non j'y viens après avant d'accord débat
simpliste
tout cela il n'y a pas un seul de ces
chapitres dans lequel la mondialisation
ni bruxelles ni l'europe ni la moindre
responsabilité
vous pouvez dire c'est beau mais moi je
m'appelle démontrait non vous n'allez
pas me le démontrer parce que c'est vrai
l'éducation bruxelles n'y est pour rien
et l'europe n'y est pour rien c'est fou
de notre ventre c'est faux
mais l'éducation depuis 30 ans est
restée bien est-ce que vous me laisser
finir mais d'accord mais donc
l'éducation d'appliquer rien du tout si
les si les les directives de l' ocde de
l'union européenne et qui sont ils en
tout les mêmes c'est tout les mêmes
partout monsieur bayrou je vous le
démontre quand vous voulez mais vous
pouvez me démontrer ce que vous voulez
je suis enseignant je suis chargé des
parents mais pourquoi vous pouvez aussi
l'année c'est pas vrai depuis 30 ans
j'ai été ministre de l'éducation
nationale et bah oui pendant quatre
années
je connais un tout petit peu mieux le
système éducatif que vous excusez moi je
veux dire un frère et bien donc
écoutez moi pas une seule des décisions
qui ont été prises en vost
les analyses et pas une seule des
décisions qui sont prises en france dans
le domaine de l'éducation dans le
domaine de la formation professionnelle
si important dans le domaine de la
situation de l'entreprise
pas une seule de ces décisions ne vient
d'ailleurs ni de bruxelles mais vous
pouvez dire non même si je pense à mes
bons
mais ni de berlin mais de la
mondialisation ça vient de chez nous
c'est pas vrai l'abolition des
frontières ça vient pas de chez nous au
plus tôt c'est les politiques se sont
soumis à ces règles
les négociations commerciales ça ne
vient pas de chez nous ou plutôt c'est
la france à l'europe qui a négocié aux
gens problème ça la monnaie unique ça ne
vient pas de chez nous comment vous
pouvez dire ça c'est des mêmes
références pascal vanhove qu'elle a mené
une île quasi le peuple français a
choisi et les élus foncé ont choisi un
film en vous poser de nouveau l'idée
qu'on a accepté
heureusement je suis d'accord je ne suis
pas le contraire quand notre pouvoir
accepter mais ne dit pas comment sa
nouvelle série kung fu et ce concert des
insanités pareil sans faire attention
réfléchissez aux problèmes en oeuvre
attendez je finis le le problème du
projet heureux le l'orientation du
projet européen de la france a été
choisie par des dirigeants français oui
adoptée par le peuple français une fois
et compris le général de gaulle une fois
pour la monnaie unique compris le med-it
pas une fois que si une fois pour les
uns quand quand elle a refusé
franchement tous les députés sont assis
dessus de deux choses l'une ou bien on
va s'arrêter ou bien travailler nos
conversations à l'origine le peuple a
choisi trois jours il a refusé en 2005
66 je regrette c'est que je m'en moque à
m'interrompre mais cholet
je veux finir mes phrases je vous laisse
finir vos freins me regarde et vous
donner ce spectacle déplorable des gens
qui parlent les uns par dessus les
autres donc excusez moi peut-être ça
vous embête pas du tout mais j'affirme
que ce sont des décisions françaises qui
sur tous ces sujets et sur le sujet du
projet européen ont créé la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes
on peut être en désaccord sur le projet
européen et moi je crois que c'est
essentiel vous savez lorsque le général
de gaulle est revenu au pouvoir en 58
on avait voté ou adopter le traité de
rome en 57 quelques mois auparavant et
on va d'ailleurs en fêter l'anniversaire
dans des circonstances sont pas très gai
donc on a et vous savez que le général
de gaulle s'était opposé au projet
européen sur la défense européenne
on peut discuter éternellement traverser
la baie tort ou raison mais la question
est là et quand ils arrivent au pouvoir
en 58 ses conseillers lui apporte une
décision assigné indiquant qu'on sort du
traité de rome c'est à dire du marché
commun le marché des six pays qui allait
désormais avoir un marché commun ce que
vous appelez l'abolition des frontières
et général de gaulle un marché comme un
des six volets précisé
et le général de gaulle donc la décision
s'était on en sort général de gaulle a
pris son stylo et il a écrit en marge
cette phrase formidable il a écrit non
point ils sont forts mais ils ne le
savent pas tout ça parce que des hommes
politiques majeurs mendès-france à les
refuser et est un des sept qui avaient
voté contre il était monté à la tribune
pour dire que la france ne pourrait pas
résister à l'allemagne et je regrette de
dire que en mieux en 2001 il ya à peine
14 ans
la france est très au dessus de
l'allemagne réunifiée al the band et de
très loin elle vient a nommément c'est
tout le monde dit l'allemagne s'en alla
malade de l'europe elles viennent se
réunifier la france y est dans la
croissance et avec un chômage qui est au
dessous de 7 on en rêverait aujourd'hui
simplement un certain nombre de
décisions catastrophiques sont prises
sur les 35 heures en particulier qui
entraîne ces extraordinaires il faut
regarder les courbes les courbes c'est
ça s'améliore jusqu'en 2001 et en 2002
un sas casse et toutes les courbes le
chômage le commerce extérieur toutes ses
courbes moi monsieur bayrou et ses notes
date c'est le début de la monnaie unique
et c'est pas un hasard pour moi ya pas
que les 35 heures eh bien je la
conjonction des 35 heures et de l'après
neige du toit sellali trop glisser je
crois que vous vous trouviez les
thrillers
excusez moi de vous dire que depuis des
mois grâce à la politique que fait la
banque centrale européenne et grâce à
monsieur draghi le ce que vous appeliez
de vos voeux c'est à dire la baisse de
l'euro par rapport au dollar et raison
se réalise on a baissé de 15 à 60 ans
vous avez raison et cependant c'est
d'ailleurs ça va mieux pour les
industries françaises
oui il ya moins de destructions
d'emplois oui enfin bon il suffit de
voir les statistiques
oui ça va le le problème est que la
france n'a pas résolu ses problèmes à me
battre l'allemagne engager les réformes
courageuse olga mesa c'est là mais ça me
fais vieux comme moi je ne sais pas le
fanatisme de ces mots merci et donc moi
je tousse permettez moi de répondre de
reprendre la liste très vite éducation
ça c'est notre question formation
professionnelle ça c'est notre question
situation de l'entreprise c'est notre
question prolifération administrative
qui fait qu'on passe son temps à
accabler les gens tous les familles les
deux des exigences administratives de
formulaires auquel personne ne comprend
rien et je pourrai ainsi allonger ce
sont les sujets français qui sont la
question du pays
pas du tout à mon avis la question de
l'europe ou très beaux atours ne crois
pas parce qu'il est passionnant qu'est
ce qu'on fait non seulement parce qu'il
n'y a pas de question comprenez ce que
j'ai pour moi je suis d'accord avec ça
c'est première est bel et bien une
ancienne mal de le dire mais on sait que
parce que chaque fois que vous écrivez
vous fait croire que la question est
européenne mais et halliche cyclo mais
aussi parce que la périphérie za sion 10
la france et europe et la périphérie
lisa sion céder ce je regrette de dire
et moi la grande bretagne viennent
sortie et bah oui la périphérie za sion
de la france elle se trouve annulée
la france devient leur est dû à la
gérante du bar enfin pression sur deux
vient l'heure des maîtres et vous de
l'avenir de leurs avec votre ami 30 ans
il n'empêche que le projet européen ne
cesse de s'étioler dans les faits et
dans les têtes et que curieusement c'est
quand même assez absent de la campagne
par exemple de la primaire des
républicains
oui trois trop à mon avis d'autre n'ose
en parler mais moi je vais vous en
parler voilà ça pour ça je vous pose la
question je pense qu' aucun des sujets
si terrible que nous avons devant nous
par exemple les sujets qui tiennent au
commerce international au fait que la
chine s'est arrogé ou s'est dotée d'
avantages considérables dans le commerce
international et que certains
s'apprêtent à lyon voudrait lui en
donner plus par exemple les britanniques
qui sont en train derrière le breakbeat
il ya l'idée que la grande bretagne
pourrait être la veille de 2,20 été
avancée absolument en europe mais
monsieur bâillon dudu le commerce
international s'est pas l'europe qui
négocient pour tout le monde c'est pas
l'europe qui a accepté que la chine
rentrer dans la fusée moi c'est pas
sinon ça c'est pas l'europe cee
oui et s'il ya des choses à changer je
suis pour l'échangé je dis pas non mais
voilà par exemple je dis pas que
l'europe a tout accepté mais on est fort
c'est vous même qui l'a certains en
europe voudrait que l'on accepte tout
mais on a déjà que c'est parce qu'on les
a laissés rentrer dans le mc oui ils
nous ont détruit des milliers dans des
millions d'emplois et d'un côté le code
du travail c'est de la rigolade
oui enfin moi je parle pas comme ça il
nous a détruits nous nous sommes laissé
détruire et la drogue à cause de l'eau
ni sont dans une très grande difficulté
cependant des chinois la chine se trouve
la république de chine se trouve dans
une très grande difficulté sociale
environnementale et alva et elle va
rencontrer de très grandes difficultés
l'europe n'a qu'à se battre avec ses
propres armes comme les etats unis se
battent avec leurs propres armes
mais la grande différence entre ma thèse
est la vôtre c'est que l'europe peut se
battre avec des armes
la france est désarmé a été un vocable
pour se soumettre aux états unis
c'est le projet initial de monnaie enfin
enfin cesser le b à ba aujourd'hui on le
sait tous et c'est pour ça que les
américains contraire vous avez à ce que
nous ont dit les centres ils ne sont pas
contre leur avez ici pour l'heure vous
avez écrit dans une dans une dans une
interview récente au figaro quelque
chose qui est franchement impossible à
soutenir
vous avez écrit que ce que les états
unis ont fait pour libérer l'europe du
nazisme c'était pour leur intérêt de
marché oui je maintiens je dis que
devant ceux qui sont morts chez nous
vous devriez retirer ses propos
je retiens je trouve que c'est la
réalité impensable que quelqu'un qui a
de l'écho dans la société française de
la culture aussi qui est marquant par
ses propos puissent aller dans le sens
de la thèse la plus complotistes qui
exige un côté la toîle ans qu'il errait
temps qui prétend que les états unis qui
ont fait tant de sacrifices pour nous
sauver
parce que c'est eux qui sont venus dès
la télé russe qui s'est pas vous oui
enfin c'est pas les russes nord mais
messi avait pas eu les 20 millions
d'euros jamais cassé la machine de
guerre à s'il n'y avait pas eu monsieur
bayrou si les américains nous avaient
empêché avec les anglais doit détruire
l'allemagne après la première guerre
mondiale elle n'aurait pas franchement
les sessions la dérive sociale aucune
séquelle vous êtes mais je suis pas
d'accord avec vous ici avec moi j'ai
quand même le droit c'est pas une
terrible c'est sûr excuses moi insulte
pour moi vous devez dire que votre
europe et aux us et sio nail bars et des
parlait que de ça mais c'est pas moi
notamment eric basset s'il vous plaît je
vous en prie au débat de demain qui a
lieu entre les différents prétendants à
l'investiture au monde
c'est donc
qu'attendez vous de ce oui c'est un
virage assez élégant vous l'aurez noté
négocié mais les gosses et unis
pensez-vous de ces moments où tu nous a
réconciliés ta réussite voilà je veux
bien prendre les balles moi même alors
allons-y
que va-t-il sortir de ce débat qu'en
attendez vous voilà c'est dit à peu près
comme moi je n'en sais rien je trouve
cette primaire pas à bien des égards
ridicule je suis contre je les dis le
principe oui oui mr la manière dont on
va faire dialoguer des gens qui vont
d'yvon avoir la parole une minute chacun
cela dit ça vaut peut-être mieux que le
débat qu'on a vu avec trempé non clinton
non mais moi je suis pas d'accord non au
moins s'affrontent voilà c'est tout
c'est peut-être vu le dire mais ils
s'affrontent
non mais je suis assez d'accord ils
gagneront la une minute chacun c'est
grotesque voilà et donc jouglar je
crains qu'il n'y ait pas grand chose qui
en sortent je pense que le débat
important sera entre les deux tours si
débat entre les deux tours il ya entre
juppé entre juppé sarkozy ce sera là il
y aura un débat important
le débat du premier tour je vois pas
très bien ce qu'il peut en sortir cela
dit je souhaite qu'ils en sortent le
meilleur j'aimerais bien que à un moment
donné on ait l'impression d'un peu
d'oxygène dans la vie politique sans
cesse plus en plus délétère la salle
comment une réconciliation après est
possible
entre des gens qui vont se castagner en
étant c'est la politique
non c'est plus profond que ça on se
souvient de copé fillon quand même en
2010 profond que cela moi je ne crois
pas enfin je crois
tout montre qu'il y a au sein de la
droite française un affrontement radical
au sens de racines du terme entre deux
visions peut être plus c'est toujours
les bonapartistes et les organistes en
même temps oh oui enfin je sais pas bien
moi je me suis jamais reconnu dans cette
différence là parce que je ne me
reconnais interviendra là et c'est
interdit dans les deux mondes à manta le
lou va va avoir la parole parce qu'il a
dit mais on est en train de discuter
et donc voilà donc moi en tout cas si si
il pouvait se faire le miracle avait dit
qu'il m'arrivait de croire au miracle
que ça prenne un peu d'auteurs
j'aimerais ça de hauteur de spontanéité
de rire d'intelligence d'authenticité
hélas à petit voilà carrément la
résurrection
franchement moi je m'intéresse
absolument pas ce débat je voudrais
quand même évoquer avec vous quelque
chose qui me semble quand même plus
fondamental tu engages de valeur la
france celle de l'europe ce qui se passe
actuellement en syrie via la russie on a
appris hier que voilà monsieur poutine
ne se sentait pas le bienvenu qu'il
annulait sa visite moi je vous demande
en tant que français en tant qu'européen
quelle attitude il faut avoir avec
monsieur poutine avec la russie qui est
coupable et actrice de crimes massifs
entre l'humanité et de crimes de guerre
moi ça me paraît quand même plus
fondamental je regrette de briser un peu
le le déroulé de l'émission que le débat
entre les sept prétendants à la primaire
des républicains suis un peu c'est une
question que je trouve très lourde
alors on va prendre quelques frappes
qu'il y ait aujourd'hui en syrie des
choses épouvantables je n'ai aucun doute
que c'est vrai que poutine et d
l'idée d'entrer dans le dans le dans le
conflit contre des shs and co alors
c'est vrai ce que bombarder la salle est
vrai et qui a tort à l'appui a pas de
combattants britanniques dont les
enfants passaient les mêmes c'est
al-qaïda c'est pareil
bon c'est pour ça qu'il a dit à une qu
on est d'accord savoir tout ça à ces
données est ce que nous pouvons entrer
dans un conflit avec la russie de long
terme
moi je pense qu'il faut être très
prudent face de cette perspective je
pense que la perspective historique de
l'europe c'est d'avoir avec la russie
des relations qu'ils soient des
relations authentiques dur franches dont
il faut mais qu'ils soient pas des
relations systématiquement conflictuelle
d'accord c'est sur la frange à ce que
nous allons faire dans cette affaire la
faire courir de très grands risques à l'
équilibre du continent européen et à l'
équilibre du monde de même que j'ai pas
du tout à prouver que françois hollande
a ni le sa visite en pologne
parce qu'on peut pas être contre la
pologne contre la russie contre l'europe
de l'est contre où est ce qu'on va
non mais là ce sur des populations
civiles qui sont écrasés sous les
banques est ce qu'on veut c'est ce que
j'avais on évite la franchise n'a pas
encore consisterait la franchise envers
lui évidemment qu'on va pas aller
envahir la russie ni bombardé moscow
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
selon oui je pense que l'europe devrait
avoir une présence plus concertée entre
elle et une présence qui vise en effet à
des corridors humanitaires pour qu'on
puisse sauver les populations civiles
mais moi par exemple je n'ai jamais
approuvé l'idée qui était celle
concomitamment de nicolas sarkozy le
premier de françois hollande le second
et d'alain juppé le troisième
les trois étaient d'avis de bombarder
civils la syrie je considérais adra que
c'était une folie
il se trouve qu'il y as en syrie une
mosaïque de minorités dont les minorités
chrétiennes ne sont pas les mêmes et je
n'ai pas envie de faire litière de leur
existence et donc il ya là quelque chose
nous nous sommes mis nous avons mis le
monde dans une situation effroyable à la
suite d'un certain nombre d'intérimaires
sur la mairie dont certaines étaient
françaises et l'aï remis américaine en
libye a oui la version américaine
je vous rappelle que je suis monté à la
tribune pour soutenir chirac alors que
j'étais dans une situation assez
conflictuelles avec lui contre mes
propres amis qui tous étaient pour les
gones à y arriver à mary carmes et je
suis monté à la tribune pour soutenir
ceux reçus à la roue vous ravissent et
et je suis non non c'est pas ironique du
tout plaisanterie mise à part la je
plaisante pas c'est pas du tout ironique
je ne me moque pas c'est très sérieux me
ravit c'est pour deux raisons d'abord
sur le fond parce que comme vous le
savez sans doute je suis tout à fait
mille fois d'accord et vous et quand
j'ai pu écrire sur ces sujets là j'ai
dit une chose en moins bien vous mais
surtout sur les conséquences qu'il
faudrait en tirer
parce que quand vous nous dites l'europe
doit avoir une position de rapprochement
avec la russie
vous parlez d'or sauf que l'europe comme
vous dites c'est à dire bruxelles fait
exactement le contraire parce que
l'europe comme vous dites c'est à dire
bruxelles est assujettie au hachis pts 2
attendons-nous matin tu attends c'est
important ce que je dis n'est pas non
pas la france et l'allemagne vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire
bruxelles l'appareil bruxellois
deuxièmement quand vous nous dites
l'europe quelle europe la pologne
vous comme moi on connaît l'histoire de
la pologne c'est une histoire tragique
ils ont été découpés en morceaux par les
russes et les allemands et c'est normal
qu'ils aient plan de la russie c'est
tout à fait normal
d'accord avec moi donc nous on n'a pas
la même histoire au contraire ça a été
notre allié de revers pendant ainsi nous
ont sauvés en 14 hockey et en 40 donc
c'est pas la même histoire dont 14,14
louis contient 7 moyens mais on tient en
quatre ans on tient pas la marne
les russes qui bloque pas eu
toi entre parenthèses je vais faire
encore hurler bayrou mais quand tu dis
crimes de guerre bombardements de civils
les américains à dresde hiroshima
entièrement d'accord chez nous tu veux
d'accord donc il ya un vrai problème qui
est un la sujet l'assujettissement de
l'appareil bruxellois à washington et 2
la différence tout à fait naturelle
d'intérêt des états nations européens
d'histoire des arts nations européens
les allemands donc du commerce avec les
russes les vous avez compris et à la
mairie je ne suis d'accord avec rien de
cette dernière casquette battu maret
alors je vais oui mais elle va être net
par les courtes nettes
il n'ya pas d'assujettissement
bruxellois parce qu'il n'ya pas de
bruxelles ya passé l'après-midi a pas de
politique européenne
il n'y a pas de politique bruxelloise il
ya une absence de politique bruxellois
c'est normal c'est leur philosophie
non mais alors vous ne dites pas le
contraire si leur philosophie c'est
juste un maniaque ne rien faire le droit
commerce donc on se couche dans
washington qui diable et moi
non il n'ya pas d'assujettissement il ya
une absence et deuxièmement cette
absence elle vient de quoi elle vient de
ce qu'il n'y a pas de voix de la france
parce que sur les deux quinquennats
successifs
je vous rappelle que nicolas sarkozy
était allé à washington dire que chirac
avait tort absolument alors qu'il était
membre du gouvernement vous avez tout à
faire et dans des termes qui ont fait
que en tout cas moi à la place du
président de la république de l'époque
j'en aurai tirer les à 2003 et
conclusion immédiate le sur les
dernières années la france a été absente
c'est il ne peut pas y avoir de
politique européenne s'il n'y a pas une
proposition française forte c'est à dire
s'il n'y a pas un président de la
république française car c'est de lui
que dépend la politique internationale
s'il n'y a pas un président de la
république française qui sache où il va
et qui est la force ou la puissance de
le dire vous croyez encore dans l'es6
entendu général de grenoble où la ligne
a été coupée en deux
c'est la france qui dirige les jeux de
service blancs en déplaise à monsieur
zemmour les deux problèmes sont sains
les crimes de guerre russe en ce moment
et l'annexion de la crimée c'est à dire
une partie de la souffrance et la crime
ici c'est pas bruxelles c'est caustique
mais merci beaucoup monsieur bayrou
d'être venu sur le plateau car non vous
ne faites pas ce que vous voulez je suis
le père fouras transport et ses montages
est important ici car c'est le moment
d'accueillir notre chroniqueur tanguy
pastureau qui alors c'est un peu
ratatine la semaine politique à coup de
photos montrent que tanguy c'est à vous
je suis heureux de vous retrouver la
belle père d'éric et madame boutons mais
oui allô dernier est lourd et naulleau
c'était début mai cinq mois deux mois
commence on sait par six quand vous dire
j'ai un ami qui bosse à la préfecture
qui m'a dit toi mon pote tu as la belle
vie enfin la cei est ainsi repartie fin
de la saison le 7 novembre
alors bien sûr nous nous sommes tous
revu un il y a un mois pour la photo de
rentrer et cette année regarder la
parité est totale il y a deux femmes
deux hommes tous blancs et à gauche une
personne de couleur
eric zemmour qui a bien profité de son
escapade il a rencontré des allemands
des anglais donc maintenant il est pour
l'europe du point de vue des
dermatologues ça c'est une
radicalisation express alors cette
semaine karine lemarchand animatrice de
l'amour est dans le pré s'est lancé dans
l'interview de politique avec bruno le
maire qu'elle a essayé de traire un
réflexe le maire avait l'air content
mais le tournage a été interrompu alors
monsieur bayrou voc est apte à la base
éleveurs si elle confond ses émissions
elle va essayer de vous refiler iii
vieille fille qui n'ont pas vu loot me
82 ni même un petit renard alors cette
semaine michel sapin le ministre qui
gère les finances du pays ce qui n'est
pas compliqué vu qu'il nous reste 14
euros jean s'est rendu au mondial de
l'auto et c'est une révolution au niveau
de la sécurité routière puisque c'est la
première fois qu'un sapin rentrer dans
une voiture c'était un accident
cette super le t-rex de la vème
république a visité un salon du manga où
il a creusé regarder la fée clochette
qui en 2016 est gaulé comme zahia
je pense que même blanche neige à des
implants mammaires alors juppé a dit à
clochettes salut bébé moi j'ai 70 piges
mais j'ai la pêche je vieillis pas je
suis peter pan de veux-tu voir la plume
de mon chapeau 1 la bazouge
à la base électorale de juppé regarder
ce sont des filles déguisées en chat
avec de la fourrure jamais on n'aurait
pensé voir ça un jour sans prendre avant
du lsd juppé a établi son qg de campagne
à disneyland dans la hutte de porcien
alors cette semaine les gigis un jeune
avec juppé ont fait la fête alors idole
et alors ils ont tout un attirail des
chapeaux 1 qui donnerait l'air con à un
détenteur d'un bac + 18 des gros doigts
alain juppé 1 c'est le candidat des
proctologue de ballons voilà c'est la
première boum organisée par un senior or
ce soir est jean-luc les airs alors
juppé est tellement à la mode que des
gamins mais c'est fou un fork des pulls
à isle of péju un juppé en verlan
c'est plus facile à perte avec kosciusko
morizet les juges mais c'est 3 où il
domine hollande en 7102 ces 2010 est en
berne mais jumez ces candidats qui
cherchent des traces
un bayrou en b relance allant vers lens
a fait roubaix c'est déjà pris part
adieu le public est content cette
semaine karine le marchand a déclaré
nathalie arthaud je ne sais pas qui
c'est 1 c'est pour ça qu'on aime cette
présentatrice c'est parce qu'elle est
comme nous cette semaine nicolas sarkozy
un chômeur qui se bat pour retrouver son
emploi a tenu un meeting au zénith de
paris où il a fait parler baroin l'homme
à la voix le plus la plus érotique du
monde n'a après ils ont tous fini aux
chandelles super excitée et alors c'est
fou mais regardez les fans de sarkozy
derrière portent toutes des lunettes un
du coup elles vont lire son programme il
est mal ça sent la surfacturation par
alain afflelou alors à noter que comme
péju zico sarkozy a lui aussi des
gadgets et notamment des lunettes de
soleil au mois d'octobre
s'il gagne la primaire en novembre ce
sera distribution de serviettes de plage
1 et pour les élections en mai des
moonboots c'est à dire qu'avec sarkozy
venu et bleu calendrier est en verlan
loin pour séduire les jeunes alors cette
semaine jean françois copé en pleine
interview a été visée par un verre c'est
le seul à prendre l'apéro mais dans la
gueule après le tabagisme passif copé a
rod et l'alcoolisme passif cette semaine
jean christophe cambadélis l'un des
derniers fidèles de hollande sur un
total de une personne a dit avoir vu le
président tombé amoureux des français au
long de son quinquennat - voulez mais
plus il nous est belle on a le premier
chef de talent et c'est je pense que si
demain le lâche
il nous offrait là bas cette semaine
henkel a trouvé le moyen d'avoir
facilement quatre personnes de plus dans
son comité de soutien se placer devant
un miroir
voilà c'est tout conflit passé cette
semaine anne hidalgo maire de paris a
osé la robe en cuir du vrai qu'ils
eurent d'automobilistes parisien qui a
lâché sur un banc d'arsenal
alors c'est inédit à l'hôtel de ville ni
jean tiberi nie delanoë n'avait porté
cuir ou alors sous leur pantalon on
al'impression voyager de voir une soirée
coquine ou quatre personnes sur cinq
n'aurait pas reçu le carton d'invitation
paris c'est chaud enfin cette semaine
bruno le maire le robert desnos de la
primaire auteur des rimes le renouveau
c'est bruno la primaire c'est le maire
s'est rendu au marché de boulogne
billancourt
alors il s'est vendu lui même regarder
devant la boucherie hne
donc on avait le choix entre dont
regarder de la langue de veau de la
langue de boeuf et donc de la langue de
bois c'est le seul politique à oser
entrer en concurrence regarder à droite
c'est incroyable avec une queue de boeuf
et la confiance en lui le bon gars bref
quelle belle semaine
merci tendu pour ce moment avec françois
bayrou
merci beaucoup d'être venu une petite
dernière question peut-être est-ce que
pour vous la présence du fn au second
tour et inéluctable vous avez une minute
non merci merci merci et à la semaine
prochaine pour pour la deuxième numéro
de la cellule de deux animaux de la
saison 2 n d'ici là restez zen sur
paris-première bonsoir